Hello Freak bitches.
He's now basically the
ultimate golden snitch.
Now why you say Golden Snitch was golden?
Because he's at another level,
but he's not a snitch.
He's an investigator.
Yeah.
He's not like a garnish evolve.
A snitch will be Victor Conte.
Victor Conte is a snitch.
He got content on top,
but he didn't even rat on
people when he got caught you.
He can't even call him a snitch.
You call them a postoperative because
he used rats where I come from,
but he's.
See,
here's the thing.
He used to be involved in it.
He's not involved in anymore.
Now he's going after people
who are involved with.
So what is that?
That's like an informer.
But can I ask you a question?
Did they ever actually.
Jamie says yes joe,
to kind of be a snitch because he's
really revealing all this backstory like,
well,
I just love this time.
It's fun because it's
really the same thing.
That's what's going on with podcasts.
You guys don't need any sort of account.
You guys kind of have a company though.
You kind of have fox.
We're,
I mean,
not really because again,
they don't tell you what to do.
They can't try and not where they started,
but they can't do it.
I've actually been so good.
That's what this whole,
they know.
If they're like,
hey,
don't do that.
I'm like,
what can I do?
What the thing is like,
you guys have an advantageous
position in the relationship.
It's not like a regular show
where they could fire you from it.
Yeah.
If they fire you,
you will have zero impact,
but also it actually helped us because
just tell everyone what went down and I
will tell all the dirt
and I will blast picture.
I'm a snitch.
I'm a big skew.
Fucking.
I've always been a snitch.
I'm that golden snitch.
Truth comes out golden
before someone makes a photoshop of
you in the salt liberalize outfit.
Says Golden Snitch,
golden snitch.
Somebody made it already.
Jamie made it while working on the show.
Jamie.
We did a lot of direction,
right?
You did.
Well,
I ran into you in New York when you
were doing the Chappelle show with
Chappelle.
The very first episode I would work
at the beginning at Dave Chappelle's.
Not Crazy.
That's the other thing
that drives me nuts,
you know,
because he walked away,
but I saw those people micromanage
them and drive him nuts.
They were so rude.
Now Dave's not crazy.
He's a friend of mine.
I love him.
He's a very,
very brilliant guy.
Very smart and aware.
And how's the Kahunas to do what you said,
to quit,
to walk away from 50 million bucks.
I'm uncomfortable saying this story,
but just trying to use.
Cause I know the
semantics of the language.
I'll just say what happened.
People can make whatever,
but I was.
I was directing the show and white comedy
central executives came down and asked
me.
They said,
can you tell Dave not
the same nigger so much?
And I said,
Dave,
the white comedy Central
Executive in front of them,
the same.
So much.
Dave goes,
bobcat push off.
What did you say?
It was really weird and
awkward and then they left.
Like,
I intentionally thought,
well this will be embarrassing for them.
This is exactly what you told me.
Oh good.
Cause because,
yeah,
I don't think I've ever heard that story,
but yeah,
I'm a witness to that insanity.
Just sell it,
sell it to the American people.
What is wrong,
what can be fixed and what can
Gary Johnson do to fix this?
I'll make
a pitch for myself and that is,
is that I think I really
am a unique package.
Uh,
I am fiscally conservative.
I'm,
I'm as frugal a human
being as you've ever met.
But that doesn't mean that I'm cheap.
It just means that I
spend my money wisely.
I got to serve as governor
of New Mexico for two terms.
Uh,
I served as governor of New Mexico for
two terms as a Republican in the state
that's two to one democrat.
I got reelected by a bigger margin the
second time than the first time made a
name for myself as a real government
skeptic vetoing legislation.
I may have vetoed more legislation than
the other 49 governors in the country
combined.
Coupled with that,
um,
I'm socially tolerant.
I'm socially liberal.
Look,
you and I should be able to make decisions
in our own lives that only affect our
own lives as long as those decisions
don't adversely affect others.
And then there is a very real
terrorist threat out there.
It exists.
Um,
but I do believe that our military
interventions have resulted in making
situations worse,
not better.
So I'm a real skeptic when it comes to
government and the fact that government
is too big.
Uh,
I've been an entrepreneur my entire life.
I know what it is to hire and fire.
I know what it is to share in the profits.
And what a magic formula that is,
that when you share in the profits,
amazingly the profit
pie grows significantly.
Uh,
I've been an athlete my entire life.
Bit of an oxymoron is a 63 year old,
but what athletics has taught me is,
you know,
life is putting one foot
in front of the other.
Athletics has taught me that anything
that can go wrong will go wrong.
It's how you deal with failure that
ultimately determines your success.
Look,
things go wrong all the time.
You can crawl up on the couch,
you can declare yourself a victim,
you can give up,
or you can recognize that that's just
part of life and wake up the next day with
a smile on your face and continue to
move forward and just do your best.
I've told,
I've told the truth.
Uh,
I think it's really hard to do any damage
to somebody who's willing to tell the
truth regardless of the consequences.
And then I admit mistakes.
I think mistakes have a way of.
So compounding themselves just because
people don't acknowledge those mistakes.
So given this pitch,
all I want to do is just get in the
polls that determines who is in the
presidential debates.
I think that if I'm in
the presidential debates,
I have an opportunity of
actually winning because of
this package that you've allowed
me to present here today ago.
Thank you.
That's how I act is important.
Not what I think.
So tell me to keep my thoughts purist.
Like,
my thoughts are mine.
They're mine.
I do what I want with them.
That's right.
So if you girlfriend,
I was just thinking about
that big country fucker Lego,
a piece a week coming out
of the corner of his mouth,
Nazi Tattoo on the back of his neck.
Just lay in Dick.
God bless her fat Dick.
God bless her.
Whatever.
She's into like a sailor's forearm.
I am not asking.
Yeah,
I mean,
no.
Do you have moments like
in your relationship where
you know you're with each
other for your life?
This is a.
This is a long time thing.
I feel like we ended yet on music.
There's times when you're all of a sudden,
oh no,
no,
do it.
Jamie went to get some
incredible hulk walkaway museum
and there's times when you
were into her and that's it.
There's times when there's
times when all of a sudden you,
you,
you about to say this times
and she's not in the EU.
Yes.
Unacceptable.
Walk.
Be a man.
Suck it up.
There's boots.
You know what?
It not that psyched with
me right now with a boner.
You choose to Viagara you
get your Dick hard as a rock.
I'm not saying you don't do those things.
What I'm saying is you don't
ask her why you don't ask what?
What is it like?
You don't want to know these things.
I don't want to know why she's unhappy.
I want to know.
I just want her to keep
her thoughts to herself.
If she's bang some big
redneck in a truck stop.
No,
you don't want.
I don't want to do.
You don't want to know if she's
actually being or thinking about being.
I don't want to know anything.
You don't want anything.
Oh No.
What a good husband.
You want her to just be a good mom.
A good wife and eat my bread.
And how about she cooks
something once in a while.
Why my baking bread?
Like I'm an old lady.
Why am I running around
with flower on my shirt?
She's sitting on the couch.